thank you so much for being here oh my
god no I think you're hilarious and I
also I find you a very very attractive
woman that means so much to me coming
from you
really everything you just said this is
my make-a-wish I'm pretty sure that's
what this show is now you can go see
coming in early that's only 30 minutes
it's fine yeah then you go right back to
treatment you know it's funny because I
was thinking about the last time you
were here you were talking so much about
the ways in which you're not happy about
your period which I think it's very
common for everybody but you last time
we're saying that you had your lips my
lips dying we're not happy no and I
haven't done it again um I did it only
because I got trolled like on Instagram
I posted something about Trump and some
troll was just like shut up you thinlit
[ __ ] I was like oh they know it they
see it I've always known that much about
myself like I know I'm a tlb but I
didn't know anyone
like damn it I gotta fix it so that he
changes his mind about me and so you
were seemingly approval you're seeking
the approval of just your horrible daddy
eighty-six and it works he's a Hillary
supporter now no I'm just it doesn't
change anything what you do is you fix
what they make fun of you about and then
they can't say that anymore but then
they find something else which usually
I'm used to getting like shut up they
use real just like you don't have an ass
you flit ass short and I'm just like oh
I've been dealing without having an ass
my whole life like I've never had an ass
I grew up in the age of JLo it's been a
problem my whole life like I usually
just go I lost it in the war I've never
had a butt yeah how does that work how
do you lose your ass and no heart
I never land mine I saved every one of
my company get out of the way boys my
ass is here to save the day yeah I've
never done I've never had on an acident
and it you know it hurts to sit on a
metal chair feel good but yeah I don't
care about like that anymore I'm used to
I'm used to getting that because there's
nothing I can do about it I look like
I'm carrying around two cellphones in my
back pockets and all God it's not a good
luck I once actually had pants wet pants
made you know juicy sweatpants as you
see on the button my eye you have a show
on Comedy Central and as a gift they all
made sweatpants for me that said sorry
on the bus I really did it I've always
wanted to have them I do feel like I owe
someone an apology I you know what I
usually feel fine about not having an
ass like I've really embraced it like
you got it you don't have one and
no listen first of all a hundred percent
correct you da i have thin lips and I
have absolutely no but it's been
discussed many times people on my staff
constantly ridicule me for having
there's nothing there I've tried yes
what does I've tried mean I'm sorry
you've done squats like people are
always like do more squat doesn't matter
I could I could you know I could do a
hundred thousand squats a day nothing
would change there's no musculature
there to develop there's nothing there
that's what I've always felt connected
to you I remember one time back in like
you are a fan of my work you have to be
del Crowe to your feet I just remember
you like talking about having a long
back back in the day and I was like I
have one too I can make it in showbiz as
well Conan did it yeah I did it so
anyway to do it yeah is this know me get
this straight because I do find you
hilarious and attractive you're I'm told
you're single again
are you single by choice I mean I mean
yeah it sucks I have to wear makeup all
the time cuz I'm single I can't risk
taking this out and about barefaced you
just you walk out of your you I can't
trust that someone's gonna like see my
inner beauty in line at CVS if I have no
makeup on they're not gonna like sense
that I'm a good friend or like I'm funny
or I do anal like they're not gonna know
anything just by looking at my way to
get a t-shirt that said specifically
right about that last part you know yeah
the message could be given